you should have gone for the head
grab some delicious yo magic and your
prescription of nexus antidepressant
because it's probably gonna be at least
over a year before we get one division
season two five in a glass case of
emotion
but fear not the season finale had some
major clues hinting at what's next for
wanda and in this video we'll be taking
a deep dive into
all those hidden details including both
post-credits scenes
and what they're setting up for both
season 2 and marvel phase 4. so wipe
away your tears with an extra strength
lagos paper towel and make sure to like
and subscribe because here
we go well if it isn't the old neighbor
stealing your kids to
duke it out on the street scenario agnes
harkness has billy and tommy tied up
like puppets and i still can't believe
billy is the kid from the haunting of
hill house
this whole scene is kind of ironic since
the entire season it's been
wanda who's had people under her control
now it's agnes with wanda's children
she's their puppet master agnes even has
a callback to age of ultron saying of
wanda's control of dottie
what are you doing to her you're making
her say this she's your meat puppet i
just cut her strings but
now i'm free with her kids in danger
wanda
attacks but unbeknownst to her that's
exactly what agnes wants
my powers work out here did you forget
no dear
i'm counting on it that's because agnes
has the ability to absorb these powers
or at least
suck the power out of those who attack
her we saw this back in 1693 when the
coven she was a part of attempted to
kill her instead she ended up training
them of all their power turning them
into these shriveled corpses
this is exactly what happens to wanda
after her first attack her hand begins
to decompose
agnes wants to know how wanda was able
to conjure magic as powerful as the hex
the energy field which surrounds
westview and holds all its townspeople
under wanda's spell
you see agnes has been waiting centuries
for someone with wanda's powers
it's taken her years to perfect smaller
spells like transmutation so
she's naturally curious how wanda was
able to learn such powerful magic in a
small amount of time
and she wants that power due in large
part because she believes
wanda is undeserving i take power from
the undeserving
it's kind of my thing wanda ends up
throwing a ruby colored car at agnes in
an homage to the house falling on
another famous witch the wicked witch of
the east from the wizard of oz
only this time it's crushing a witch
into a house instead of a house falling
on a witch
coincidentally oz the great and powerful
is playing at the coronet theater
another disney film that came out in the
year 2013.
coronet also refers to a crown one which
wanda receives as she fully transforms
into the scarlet witch
and if this witch beef couldn't get
papercrash enough that's supposed to be
spicy
in comes white vision to duke it out
with the vision we saw a white vision in
the
end credits of episode viii he's
basically agent hayward's new version of
vision which he was able to power up
using the drone that was imbued with
wanda's powers they retrieved a few
episodes ago
and it seems this energy is fed through
a stark arc reactor in place of the mind
stone
agnes says to wanda of white vision's
arrival oh
this is awkward your ex and your
boyfriend together at the same
party which basically refers to these
two visions having
two different histories with wanda white
vision who holds all the memories from
her past
buried away in his data core and the
vision being the version
created by wanda in westview hayward
doesn't care that he's basically gone
rogue to make sure white vision emerges
from the hex
victorious no one's going to care once
i've eliminated wanda maxumron
they'll believe that the vision who
emerges from the west view rubble is the
same one she illegally
tried to bring back to life it's kind of
hinted at in episode 8 that hayward
wanted wanda to steal vision's body
as she was the only one that could bring
him back to life and he wants vision
alive so that vision can be used as a
weapon
agent jimmy wu meanwhile is handcuffed
by hayward's men but easily escapes
saying
flourish a nod to episode 2's a magic
show
flourish when wanda arrives downtown
dennis the town's mailman says don't
shoot
i'm just the messenger the same line he
says to agnes
also in episode two don't shoot i'm just
a messenger
i also like how he works for a company
called presto the word of magician says
while pulling a rabbit out of a hat
which is exactly what animal is on his
baseball cap agnes tells wanda that the
darkhold the magic tone we first saw in
agnes basement has an
entire chapter devoted to the scarlet
witch not very uplifting since she calls
it the book of the damned it's also
pretty ironic she stands in front of a
giant billboard for squeaky shine a
cleaner that uses the power of earth
since the power both wanda and agnes use
magic
is derived from other dimensions wand is
told she's a witch but she's like not a
witch and she better not be because
according to agnes the scarlet witch's
destiny is to destroy
the world it's your destiny to destroy
the world man that's a bummer meanwhile
we get our first glimpse this episode of
monica rambo who we last saw in the
post-credits scene of
episode 7. she's been taken hostage by
ralph boner
boner agnes minion who was cast to play
wanda's dead brother pietro ralph also
happens to be the name of agnes husband
who she constantly referred to
throughout the season but who we never
saw now there are some people who think
he might be the person
agent wu was looking for who went
missing from the witness protection
program but there's very little evidence
to back that up like when he laughs at
his own last name which would have been
given to him
as a new identity little does ralph know
that monica's entire molecular structure
has changed
this is hinted at in earlier episodes
when her scans come back blank
and they need to re-test her blood i
won't get too in-depth in this video
about it but
monica has basically turned into a more
powerful version of captain marvel with
the added bonus of being able to absorb
and manipulate the energies of other
heroes we get a brief taste of this when
she absorbs one of wanda's blasts and
lands unscathed she can also see a
different spectrum of energy with her
eyesight hence why she's able to see the
purple glow emanating from the vines in
agnes basement but wanda doesn't see it
she takes off boner's necklace which is
just a very weird thing to say
which was glowing purple the item agnes
used to control him if you're looking
for a more detailed explanation on
monica's powers i suggest you check out
emergency awesome's video on it i'll
leave a link in the description
agnes turns the entire town against
wanda turning off wanda's mind control
and these guys are in a lot of pain
the mom from that 70s show is like if
you won't let us go
just let us die
[Laughter]
wanda upon seeing this opens the hex
allowing the people to escape but this
has the adverse effect of destroying the
thing she loves most her
family you tied your family to this
twisted world and now one can't exist
without the other
wanda can't bear to see her family
destroyed and the opening of the hex is
short-lived but long enough to allow
hayward and his men
inside wanda takes on agnes snapping her
fingers just like samantha in bewitched
one of wanda's favorite childhood
sitcoms does meanwhile the two visions
fight in what can't be a coincidence a
library a place of vast knowledge vision
brings up the allegory of theseus in the
ship which
asks the question if you have a ship and
slowly over time replace the rotting
wood of it with newer pieces
is it still the same ship in this
scenario the two visions are the ship
and
wanda is theseus the vision is able to
unlock
whitevision's memory something he says
is not easily wiped and allows white
vision to transform from a mindless
robot to something more human
his eyes change from robotic to human to
signify this change then he's like peace
i'm out of here and we never see him
again
but we'll get more into white vision in
a bit like any good mom
wanda leaves billy and tommy in charge
of taking on all the military but as
soon as they're attacked
monica steps in and absorbs the bullets
this has to be her manifesting vision's
power not only is it the same yellow
color but being able to have objects go
through her
is exactly what vision can do and it's
possible she may have learned this while
watching the two visions fight from
ralph
or pietro's window at the beginning of
the episode wanda tries to perform one
of agnes's own tricks on her by
transporting her into the memory of the
day she was killed by her coven
this backfires when the dead witches
reanimate and call her the scarlet witch
the harbinger of chaos she blasts them
away as a scarlet crown dawns her head
fulfilling the vision she saw years ago
of a floating crowned
figure agnes gives wanda one last chance
to live pain-free in a world of her own
give me your power and i will correct
the flaws in your original spell and no
one will
ever have to feel this pain
again but wanda has one last trick up
her sleeve
she's covered the hex in protection
runes just like the one agnes had in her
basement
making any other witch butt wanda unable
to use
magic in a given space
only the witch who cast them can use her
magic
instead of killing or locking agnes up
wanda gives her what she believes to be
a worse fate
to play the role of the nosy neighbor in
west view forever
and this opens up a lot of possibilities
for us to return to west view
wanda might need agnes later on or
someone may come along and free her long
story short this is likely not the last
time we'll see
agnes i'll get you my pretty and your
little dog too
[Music]
and i killed sparky too
[Laughter]
[Music]
wand and vision both know at this point
what wanda must do
remove the hex for good and move on with
her life
i know you'll set everything right
just not for us it's a bit sad but
there's some hope here
vision has changed over the years just
like theseus's ship
who's to say he won't be back and who
knows in what form
there's also white vision now having
unlocked the memories of the past
if he has these memories are his
feelings for wanda not there as well
surely he would be looking for her but
as we'll see in a bit wanda may not
want to be found as wanda says goodbye
to her boys we finish her character arc
for this season
she started in grief unable to let go of
her family
constructing a world where she'd never
have to be in pain but this is at the
expense of others
and now she's learned to overcome her
own pain to learn that family is forever
a family is forever
we could never truly leave each other
even if we tried vision and wanda say
goodbye
he's the piece of the mind stone that
lives in her he'll always be there
even though this version of him was
created by wanda he is now
a memory made real
who knows what i might be next the show
is called
wanda vision vision isn't going anywhere
the question remains in what form he
will manifest
will it be white vision or is there
another universal reality where he still
exists more on that in a bit bonus
points if you saw the marquee playing
tanhauser gate a
location mentioned in blade runner and
also a nod to the german opera tanhauser
the story of which revolves around
redemption through love
sound familiar with wanda's
mind-controlled west view gone there's
one
final goodbye that between monica and
wanda where
wanda apologizes for all the pain she's
caused the show has never really been
about the relationship between these two
particular characters this is more of a
setup for where their characters may be
headed
outside the wandavision series wanda
tells monica
i don't understand this power
but i will which will likely be her big
arc in what season 2 will focus on if
season 1 was focused around
westview season 2 is her learning to
discover her power and unlock its
mysteries perhaps even learning how to
bring back tommy and billy
in the second post-credits scene we see
wanda in a secluded almost
norse-like location it seems as though
she doesn't want to be found
nor disturbed she's seen levitating
perhaps astral projecting
looking through the dark hold when she's
interrupted by the sounds of
tommy and billy asking for help
how can they still be alive i know a lot
of theories out there have centered
around
a multiverse and that is a possibility
magic does come from other dimensions in
the marvel universe but i can't help but
think doctor strange might be
involved here somehow maybe it's him
who's using these voices to lure wanda
out of hiding wanda's astral projecting
form here also looks similar to
strange's form when he
astral projects this allowed him to
study while his body rested wanda makes
tea while she simultaneously studies
doctor strange also oversaw 14 million
different outcomes trying to figure out
a way to destroy
thanos can wanda also use this skill for
her own gain
of course she would probably need the
time stone is there an outcome where she
can save her children
and can strange help her out elizabeth
olsen has been cast in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness
and began filming right after
wandavision so expect her post-credit
scene to tie
into that and finally we have that other
post-credit scene where hayward is
arrested and monica is met with a skrull
agent she was sent by an old friend of
her mother's who wants to meet with her
up there this has to be nick fury who we
last saw hanging out with his skrulls in
a spaceship in the mid-credits scene of
spider-man
far from home nick met young monica
rambo and captain marvel and said she
can have adventures up in space when she
can glow
too only if you learn to glow like your
auntie carol well it looks like her time
has come and we'll be seeing more of
monica in both captain marvel 2
and nick fury's own disney plus show
secret invasion
other characters like darcy lewis and
agent wu are likely to return next
season too
they were huge fan hits with some even
calling on them to have their own
disney plus spin-off that's all for
today guys thanks for watching and
please make sure to like and subscribe
i'm always coming out with new
videos for more bad takes you can always
follow me on twitter and instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much